hallo mein name ist luca ich bin
schlecht in ag.de damit dieses spiel
allerdings trotzdem spaß macht habe ich
mir gedacht mache ich eine neue serie
und zwar challenges in ag.de in der tat
in dieser serie könnt ihr mir und in die
kommentare schreiben welche challenge
ich beim nächsten mal machen soll quasi
so was wie dieses challenge accepted was
ich vor ein zwei drei vier fünf tausend
jahren mal auf einem kanal in minecraft
gemacht habe die erste challenge kommt
heute von mir und zwar habe ich mir die
challenge gesetzt immer wenn ich einen
anderen spieler es muss ich zehn
sekunden auf der stelle stehen bleiben
wir machen die challenge ein bisschen
anders und zwar setze ich mir jetzt
einen timer auf eine minute und nach
jeder minute muss sich quasi 10 10
sekunden einfach ja genau da muss ich
zehn minuten auf der stelle bleiben das
heißt gleich wenn der heimat zu ende ist
muss ich einfach zehn sekunden auf der
stelle stehen bleiben und mehr oder
weniger hoffen dass mich niemand frisst
was ist denn das für eine fette kugel da
rechts alter komm wir machen das
trotzdem noch wenn ich jemanden esse
dass ich dann auch zehn sekunden bleiben
muss das heißt wenn ich jetzt niemanden
fraser fraysse frei kompanie dazu wie so
sind denn alle so schnell in diesem
spiel und wenn ich dann mal dass tylers
abgelaufenen stellen auf der stelle
stehen bleiben sieben sechs fünf vier
drei zwei eins und ich kann mich wieder
bewegen und der neue teil läuft auch
schon wieder
nein freunde detail meist vorbei okay
okay ich bleibe stehen
12345 der timer steht wieder auf einer
minute und ich versuche mich jetzt hier
mit einem anderen namen mal eben
durchzusetzen das müsst ihr eigentlich
was passiert eigentlich wenn ich
gefressen werde dann karl oder das nix
aber immer wenn ich ein fresse oder wenn
die eine minute vorbei ist dann muss ich
jetzt auf jeden fall zehn sekunden
stehen bleiben doch es ist doch nicht
war als ob man das kann doch nicht sein
diese challenge es so scheiße entweder
werde ich gefressen oder wenn ich dann
stehen bleibe passiert irgendwas scheint
ja ok timer 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 so
weitergeht so war das knapp in portugal
wie gefällt euch das lassen wir bitten
daumen hoch da wenn ihr sagt ok kommen
mehr von diesen challenge videos ich
meine das ist natürlich da nicht immer
diese zehn sekunden channel die ich mir
ausgedacht hat sondern ihr könnt mir
dann so schreiben ja spiel mal wenn nun
handschuhe an hass oder mit augen zu
oder whatever und zeigt mir das einfach
mal mit einer besorgt ist der riesig
zeigt mir das einfach mal mit einer
bewertung ob ihr sagt ja mach mer von
challenges in agra oder nein oder dich
esse jetzt stehen wir sind gleich groß
nein nein ich verstehe auch immer nie
wie einfach kaymer vorbei ok 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 9 und neuer thema läuft wieder
es denkt auch vielleicht einige junge du
bist teilweise gar nicht genau auf der
stelle sondern richtig ein bisschen das
liegt einfach daran dass es in der g
punkt so schwer ist auf der stelle
stehen zu bleiben zwar muss man die maus
perfekt in den kreis einfach rein
bewegen und dass wir kriege ich mir hin
weil ich bin schlecht auch das ist doch
nicht war als ob das ende der kette wax
crew da
wieso sind sie denn alle maßen sich in
einem dünnen körper niemand täuschen
schlagwerk o du freak [ __ ]
was soll das denn was kann ich denn
dafür so wehsely kommentar unter dem
video
luca
du bist ja so kacke du solltest das
nicht mehr spielen luca du solltest
gebannt werden von den servern niemand
mag dich luca das spiel ist nicht
gedacht für schlechte spieler bitte
spiel auch was anderes luca kannst du
überhaupt irgendeinen spiel spielen ich
streife mein leben lang durch die
savanne auf der das ist nicht wahr
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 und der neue teil
startet mein einziges ziel ist es diesen
hitler da unten zu essen oder zumindest
nicht von ihm gefressen zu werden das
ist eigentlich relativ egal aber der
frist immer mehr von diesen pünktchen
als ich möchte nur einmal ohne dich
kriege ich dich krieg ich's 11 lol oder
lose oder wandern oder dich da ich muss
doch mal irgendwann jetzt hier fressen
können das ist doch nicht war nein nein
nein
wo war das knapp alter da habe ich mal
wieder richtig glück gehabt das kann
auch nicht sein aber da kommt hitler
einfach an und versuche mich dazu fräsen
funktioniert okay ich bin das allererste
mal ein wenig größer unterwegs ich
versuche jetzt mir diese 77 777 hier
unten zu das ist doch nicht weit kommen
kommen komm komm komm ich muss doch wohl
mal irgendwie in ihr fressen können
kommen dich wenigstens nein du gehst
auch nicht das ist doch nicht wahr ich
muss doch irgendwie nein nein nein nein
nein ein 1 1 1 1 1 1 1
hu jia jia jia wir sind gleich musiker
disneys traineeship cici timers vorbei
okay 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 garde alter
ist das unfassbar wie lange kann ich
denn in diesem schild überleben da hätte
ich ja nie gedacht ich dachte ich wohin
wenigstens einmal angedacht so ganz
knapp aber es ging ja immer noch klar
also freunde wenn ihr ideen habt einfach
und in die kommentare schreiben in
welchen challenges mitmacht mega spart
also gerade wegen dieser challenge
erneut einmal läuft natürlich jetzt
schon wieder die ganze zeit und ich
denke dass es dann auch das letzte mal
dass ich stehen bleibe aber ich möchte
noch irgendwie ins fressen einfach um
kom kom kom kom kom kom kom irgendwer
von euch muss doch mal kleiner sein als
ich das ist nicht wahr ich muss doch
irgendwann fressen können das kann doch
nicht sein hier redet oder irgendwen
hier die sonne nein nein nein nein nein
ich du freddy nicht auch noch freddy
dass es kann dich seien alle sind
genauso groß wie ich möchte nur eine
person gefressen so kommen dann jetzt
noch eben hier den morgen morgen kommt
keiner vorbei wenn es vorbei 123456
bitte nicht 7 8 9 10
harbou komcom ist lewis nullkommanichts
war ich möchte nur eine gottverdammte
person von euch fressen kann es denn
wahr sein irgendwen von euch
es ist mir vollkommen egal wer es ist
ich möchte nur hier es ist nicht wahr
jetzt muss ich stehen bleiben das kann
noch nie seien 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 und ich
bin komplett alleine auf dieser
gottverdammten map ja meine lieben
freunde ich würde sagen das war es jetzt
hier von ergab um die erste folge der
challenge cup mit der 10 sekunden
challenge and euch gefallen hat würde
ich mich definitiv über eine bewertung
freuen oder will
wenn ihr ideen für weitere challenges in
der tat schreibt den sieben jahren in
die kommentare